القراءه في هذا العدد الكبير المعلن هذا
الصباح من الجيش الحديث عن ثمانيه جنود
وضباط قتلى في غزه ما هي القراءه لهذه
الحصيله في بدايه
اليوم يعني واضح هذا رد على الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي الذي يتشدق ويقول انه
وسع ودمر و وه هذه هذه نتيجه حتميه و واضح
يعني انه يكون حينما يكون هناك مزيد من
القوات الاسرائيليه وهذا ما نقوله دائما
وخاصه في المناطق المبنيه وحرب المدن وحرب
الشوارع سيكون هناك مزيد من الخسائر لانه
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كانت وقالت وصرحت اكثر من مره
انها تنتظر الجنود الاسرائيليين بفارغ من
الصبر وها هم الان يقعون فريسه للمقاومين
الف الفلسطينيين لانه معروف عاده حين انما
يكون هناك قتال مدن الذي يتحكم في الارض
هو صاحب الارض الذي يعرف طبيعتها والذي
يحمل
المعنويات بعكس الجندي الاسرائيلي الذي
يقاتل بدون روح قتاليه وبدون
معنويات كما جرى مع اللواء الجولاني
وكتيبه 31 التي
التي سحبت من الميدان نتيجه تدني الروح
المعنويه والقتاليه
فبالتالي انا بتقديري كلما توغل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المناطق المبنيه وحرب المدن
كلما يعني كبد خسائر اكبر بكثير مما كان
عليه في السابق وهذا هذا يعني يؤكد بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى الان غير قادر على
مواجهه المقاومين الفلسطينيين الذين
يملكون زمام السيطره والقياده والمبادره
والشجاعه
والبسالة يتجرد من دبابته ومن مدفعه ومن
طائرته سيصبح
اي يعني في مواجهه ال المقاتل الفلسطيني
وجها لوجه سلاح لسلاح وهنا يتفوق الذي
يحمل المعنويات وهو طبعا لهذه الحاله
المقاومه الفلسطينيه نعم المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي دينان الهجاري كان يتحدث
عن نقطه خروج المقاتلين من الانفاق
والاشتباك وهو في ذلك يشير طبعا الى سواء
تدمير الانفاق
او ربما تغير طبيعه المواجهه بفعل انتشار
المقاومين في الشوارع طبعا حسب الروايه
الاسرائيليه هل هذا مرجح لارتفاع اعداد
القتله نذكر ان المقاومه اعلنت ان عددا من
الجنود قتلوا اثناء تفخيخ هذه
الانفاق يعني المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ومذ بد العمليات العسكريه من
الشمال حتى الغرب حتى الوسط حتى الجنوب
يعني لها تكتيكاتها ومعروف في علم
الفدائيين والمقاومات
العصابيه ان المقاتل لا يقاتل عدوه في
ذروه قوته وينتظر عليها ليستخدم نقاط قوته
مقابل نقط ال نقاط ضعف العدو وهذا ما يجري
حتى الان يعني تكتيكات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ناجحه في مواجهه الجيش
الاسرائيلي حيث
انها تستطيع ان تختار اهدافها بدقه وبعنا
مثل تفخيخ
الانفاق مثل استخدام ما يمكن استخدامه كما
تم استخدامه بالامس الصواريخ التي لم
تنفجر من القذائف الام كي 84
واعيد تصديرها لمن لمن جاء بها وهو الجيش
الاسرائيلي واصطياد الدبابات انا بدي
تقديري ما زالت المقاومه تتحكم في مجريات
الامور وهي التي تنتخب اهدافها بدقه
وانتشارها على مساحه واسعه بقوات صغيره
متحركه تحمل عديد من الاسلحه المتنوعه
يساعدها في اقتناص الدبابات اذا ما اقتضى
الامر الاشتباك من مسافه صفر التفخيخ
المواجهه المباشره من مسافه صفر كل هذا
هذه التكتيكات انا بتقديري تملكها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقادره على تنفيذها
ببراءه